[Music]
so great thoughts on the house
love it good no boys very happy thank
you yeah fabulous absolutely a knockout
a good day a marvelous day I'd recommend
just emphasis to anybody thank you so
much I've learned today that this is a
safe uncomplicated way to invest your
money and your explain it you guys
explain it so perfectly
very easy to understand
that's awesome
so my name's Samuel Leeds I'm here with
Tanya and two fabulous ladies that come
from frightened you hear them in the car
talking saying oh my gosh this is
incredible
they've come from Brighton and they were
they were looking at spending their
money in some very expensive projects
with around about 8% return on
investment and then just bought some
properties in Wolverhampton expected to
get around 30% return on investments
with some immaculate HMO properties
really really good fun I'm almost a
little bit jealous but hey I've already
bought two properties this month I'm
really pleased for them so great